[Musique]
avec nous Eric Girard ministre des
Finances du Québec bonsoir bonsoir on va
d'abord parler Monsieur Girard de la
principale mesure budgétaire dans votre
énoncé c'est à dire le soutien des aînés
qui est bonifié de façon substantielle
c'était une de vos promesses d'ailleurs
mais comme on vient de l'entendre c'est
seulement pour les personnes de 70 ans
et plus et pourquoi 2000 dollars
pourquoi aussi laisser les personnes
entre 65 69 ans sans soutien
supplémentaire par exemple
mais d'abord c'est une mesure qui
généreuse elle coûte plus de 8 milliards
de dollars sur l'horizon du cadre
financier alors il faut respecter la
capacité de payer des Québécois ce que
nous avons dit c'est que la hausse de
l'inflation non anticipée depuis le
budget avait généré 14 milliards de
revenus supplémentaires sur l'horizon du
code financier et que nous redonnons 13
milliards au Québec avec le montant
ponctuel le plafonnement des tarifs et
l'aide aux aînés quant au à la décision
pourquoi 70 ans bien simplement parce
que à partir de ce sont les dix ans
c'est très difficile pour les aînés de
travailler de fournir un effort de
travail et donc d'améliorer sa situation
de revenus et donc on a choisi ce niveau
là faut faire des choix faut gouverner
et c'est un montant qui généreux mais
qui coûte quand même 8 milliards de
dollars sur l'horizon du code financier
les autres mesures monsieur Gérard entre
autres de votre bouclier anti inflation
c'était déjà connu c'est surtout vos
prévisions économiques peut-être qui ont
retenu l'attention d'abord la croissance
4 fois moins vigoureuse l'an prochain on
y échappera pas monsieur Gérard au
ralentissement non c'est indéniable que
le niveau élevé d'inflation et les
resserrement monétaire des banques
centrales engendre un ralentissement de
l'économie mondiale et le Québec c'est
une économie ouverte 45% de notre
économie est influencé par le commerce
extérieur alors c'est indéniable qu'il y
aura un c'est commencer déjà
et donc on passe de trois points 1% qui
était une année exceptionnelle en 2022 à
0,7% 2023 reste que vos prévisions sont
un peu plus optimistes que celle du
secteur privé vous avez expliqué
d'ailleurs cet après-midi que votre
énoncé a été préparé plutôt que les
prévisions du secteur privé mais votre
énoncé parlent aussi d'un taux directeur
à 4% alors qu'il y a grimpé hier à 4 et
quarts pour cent alors est-ce que vous
prévisions sont toujours justes oui on
est vraiment dans la marge d'erreur en
fait au moment où nous notre prévision
était à 0.7 le secteur privé était à 0.8
et c'est par souci transparence entre
l'ami octobre et la mi-novembre lorsque
le secteur privé s'est ajusté qu'on a
reflété ça dans les documents mais c'est
toujours avec cohérence avec ce qui se
fait dans le secteur privé et ce qui est
important de savoir c'est que le Québec
est une économie résiliente on a des
finances publiques solides ici il y a un
ralentissement économique on a on a les
moyens d'y faire face avec 8 milliards
de provision oui c'est ça vous vous
utilisez le conditionnel vous avez
présenté ce scénario qualifié
d'alternatif là vous admettez la
possibilité que l'économie du Québec
ralentisse d'un pourcent l'an prochain
c'est quoi la probabilité de ce scénario
de récession on dit que la probabilité
qui a une récession au Québec c'est sa
voisine 50% et c'est certain que lorsque
vous augmentez
les taux d'intérêt de 400 points de base
en une année mais les secteurs qui sont
à levier qui ont des niveaux
d'endettement plus élevés les individus
les ménages les entreprises qui sont
sensibles aux taux d'intérêt savoir
ralentir c'est l'impact de ces hausses
étaient où l'intérêts là c'est
extrêmement important sauf que vous avez
dans ce scénario là entre autres une
provision c'est 8 milliards de dollars
pour faire face à un choc alors quel
serait les plus grands impacts de
investissement sur les finances
publiques vous allez quand même réduire
le déficit et garder le cap sur
l'équilibre budgétaire mais c'est à dire
que nous notre rôle c'est d'être prudent
d'être responsable et comme il y a un
risque de récession mais on a des
provisions plus élevées que si ce
n'était pas le cas et avec 8 milliards
de provisions sur 5 ans ce que nous
expliquons c'est que c'est suffisant
pour faire face à une récession
c'est-à-dire une baisse des revenus du
gouvernement de 4.5 milliards une eau du
service la dette de 500 millions et ça
laisse un 2,5 à 3 milliards pour des
mesures d'aide aux entreprises ou aux
individus mais vous l'évoquez vous-même
monsieur Gérard si au ralentissement de
l'économie ça peut vouloir dire moins
d'argent dans les caves du gouvernement
or vous avez promis assez fermement une
baisse d'impôts possiblement pour le
prochain budget est-ce que c'est garanti
que ça va se retrouver dans le prochain
budget c'est notre engagement et c'est
important de
réexpliquer au québecois que notre
engagement c'est de financer les baisses
d'impôts en réduisant le poids de la
dette moins rapidement c'est pour ça
qu'on réduit les versements au fond de
générations qu'on réduirait qui sont
prévus à 5 milliards de dollars en
2026-2027 on prévoit les maintenir à
plus de 3 milliards de dollars et en
faisant ça on s'assure de ne pas toucher
ou service au Québécois c'est à dire que
la baisse d'impôts et en équilibre avec
une réduction moins rapide du poids de
la dette et quant au service santé
éducation ils sont adéquatement financés
sur l'horizon du code financier donc il
n'y a il n'y a pas de vase communicante
entre la baisse d'impôts et le niveau
des services
alors pour la baisse d'impôts je
comprends bien qu'on verra dans le
prochain budget et dans son discours
d'ouverture la semaine dernière monsieur
Gérard François Legault disait que les
cotisations régimes des rentes du Québec
pourrait devenir facultatif pour les
travailleurs de 65 ans et plus est-ce
que ça aussi c'est pour le prochain
budget mais ça c'est à dire que là vous
m'amenez ce sujet qui est important
c'est à tous les 6 ans il y a une
consultation sur le régime des rentes du
Québec et cette consultation là doit
être fait dans les prochains mois et ce
qu'on a proposé en campagne électorale
c'est d'harmoniser le régime des rangs
du Québec avec le régime de pension du
Canada c'est à dire qu'à partir de 65
ans si vous travaillez et que vous avez
déjà réclamé votre régime des rentes
vous pourriez ne plus cotiser au régime
des rentes au retour au travail de
personnes de travailleurs d'expérience
monsieur Gérard dans un contexte où on a
besoin de main d'oeuvre oui
effectivement c'est un incitatif au
travail pour les travailleurs
d'expérience bon on va terminer
sur les plats fatigue de la pandémie on
vous demander plusieurs choses réduire
le fardeau fiscal soutenir la formation
etc pourquoi ne pas avoir profité de
l'occasion aujourd'hui pour leur
annoncer un coup de pouce je pense que
nous avons été transparents il y a eu
une campagne électorale nous avons dit
que les Québécois avaient un fardeau
fiscal extrêmement élevé que la hausse
du coût de la vie avait des impacts
réels sur les ménages sur les familles
alors on a eu une hausse des revenus qui
correspond à 14 milliards de dollars sur
le code financier et on retourne cet
argent on contribuable avec le bouclier
anti-inflation aujourd'hui et on a aussi
provisionné les 3000 logements sociaux
et l'argent pour les policiers
supplémentaires à Montréal et donc 14
milliards de revenus supplémentaires 14
milliards qu'on redonne au Québécois et
je pense que on fait des choix et voilà
merci beaucoup Monsieur Gérard c'est un
plaisir merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI